ms marvel's about to embiggen her way to
a wider audience and the first trailer
for the new show has plenty to discuss
is she still an inhuman where'd she get
those cosmic powers and how does captain
marvel herself fit into all this
if you're watching the ms marvel trailer
without knowledge of the comics one of
the biggest things that'll catch your
eye is kamala khan's glowing purple
energy construct powers comic fans
though will immediately recognize that
ms marvel's abilities are vastly
different kamala who first debuted back
in captain marvel volume 7 issue 14
before headlining her own series in 2014
was originally depicted as getting her
powers when the mutation-causing teregin
mist which are traditionally associated
with the inhumans rolls through jersey
city now quick history lesson for casual
fans those aforementioned inhumans used
terrigen crystals to awaken their
dormant abilities which themselves are
the product of cree experimentation from
thousands of years ago that means yes
kamala khan is an inhuman in the comics
and after exposure to the mist she gets
what she calls embiggening power where
she can stretch and grow her limbs to
any size this makes her a polymorph
capable of expanding contracting or
reshaping her body in various ways
similar to reed richards of the
fantastic four evidently that won't be
the case in the mcu the new trailer
confirms that kamalan now has cosmic
powers which allow her to create various
energy constructs seemingly based on her
imagination at one pivotal moment she
manifests a giant shimmering energy fist
so the essence of her and biggening
powers will still be there but reshaped
for the mcu why the change it's probably
a combination of the inhumans tv series
being a flop and that a fantastic four
movie is currently in the works from
john watts so presumably marvel doesn't
want to have both kamala and reed's
power sets look too similar
[Music]
about halfway through the trailer we
watch as kamala attaches a pair of
glowing bracelets to her wrist which
causes her eyes to glow bright purple
these are most likely the nega bands
powerful artifacts that have been used
by various characters throughout comic
book history but traditionally are
depicted as having a unique connection
to captain marvel and the creed in the
comics these bands were entrusted by the
kree supreme intelligence to the
original captain marvel a cree warrior
named marvel a reimagined form of this
character was played by annette benning
in 2019's captain marvel the nega bands
have the ability to convert mental
energy into physical energy in the
comics that's meant that the various
captains marvel can shoot energy beams
gain super strength and are gifted with
an ambiguously defined cosmic awareness
in the show it looks like they'll
function similarly to a green lantern
ring either way whoever wears the mega
bands is able to wield an immense amount
of power and the fact that kamala's eyes
glow after she puts them on seems to
imply that she gains her powers after
wearing them for the first time
that said the fact that the show's nega
band's power comes from mental energy
implies that whoever wields them must
have a very active imagination which as
the trailer makes clear is a description
that very aptly applies to kamala the
trailer constantly reiterates how kamala
is often living in her own little
fantasy land whether it's through her
artwork or her love for superheroes
while the adults around her appear to be
treating her imagination as a flaw it
may be that it's exactly that trait
which allows her to harness the full
power of the nega-bands after all as
we've recently seen in chongqi and the
legend of the ten rings it takes more
than a pair of mystical bands to make a
true hero
i'm a superhero
you don't have to dig too deep in the
history of marvel comics to find the
impact ms marvel had on the industry
kamala khan was the first mainstream
muslim superhero to headline her own
book the character's debut was written
about by outlets such as npr as her
muslim heritage changed the face of
comics that makes kamala's religion her
cultural background and everything
connected to it essential to the
character and one would hope that the
same will hold true for her live-action
counterpart kamala's name is part of
that and many readers have often been
not entirely clear on the correct
pronunciation of it particularly since
it differs from the pronunciation used
by current u.s vice president kamala
harris thankfully marvel studios and
disney plus addressed that immediately
in the new trailer for ms marvel with a
quick moment where she corrects a
schoolmate on the pronunciation of her
name kamala kamala another adventure
shirt cute
even better though is that this isn't
the only nod to khan's heritage the
trailer also shows a quick shot of her
in a mosque wearing a hijab and
performing the muslim prayer known as
the salah these moments in the trailer
show that her faith and heritage won't
be disappearing as the character makes
her way from the comic book pages to
live action
throughout the wide array of marvel
movies and tv shows that we've been
lucky enough to see over the years there
have been a few rare instances where
shots taken directly from the comics are
captured perfectly on the screen for
instance it's hard to forget that
spider-man 2 shot of spider-man's
costume being dumped into a trash can
taken right from amazing spider-man
issue 50 or the moment in black panther
where killmonger throws t'challa over
the cliff well judging by the final shot
in this new trailer ms marvel is getting
the same treatment that stunning side of
this all-new hero overlooking the big
city as she sits casually on top of a
street lamp comes directly from this
2014 comic cover fittingly enough this
moment also shows that while much of the
series may feature kamala in a makeshift
captain marvel outfit she will at one
point or another get to don her own
iconic threads before the series ends we
can't wait to see her start this journey
when ms marvel arrives on disney plus on
june 8th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite mcu shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you